das gab schönen vormittag darf sich
herzlich begrüßen zur pressekonferenz
mit innenminister kg hammer und
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
das thema heute ist der grenzschutz und
österreichischen grenze ist auf dem
innenminister das wort geben das system
ist gescheitert wie komme ich zu dem
befund
wir erleben seit mehreren jahren und
dieses jahr besonders intensiv dass die
auf krebszellen an der österreichischen
staatsgrenze wieder steigen
wir haben nach europarechtlichen
vorgaben restriktionen die uns behindern
darin auch für klarheit im
österreichischen asylsystem zu sorgen
alleine wenn sie daran denken dass uns
europäische höchstgericht erkenntnisse
verbieten dublin-fälle nach ungarn oder
nach griechenland zurück zu stellen das
in fesseln die uns auferlegt werden in
der frage wie wir österreich vor
illegaler migration schützen können
wir stellen fest dass wir seit wochen
vermehrt auf briefe haben an der
österreichisch-ungarischen staatsgrenze
daher ist es notwendig gemäß unserer
drei sicherheitsnetz strategie vorsorge
zu treffen
das erste sicherheitsnetz sollte
eigentlich die eu-außengrenze sein
hier haben wir offensichtlich große
probleme weil sonst wäre es nicht so
dass die auftriebs zahlen in österreich
steigen
das zweite sicherheitsnetz das ist der
sicherheitsminister grenzsicherung der
westbalkanstaaten wir haben werden
initiative gestartet mit der plattform
gegen illegale migration um hier mit
unseren partnern vom westbalkan dafür zu
sorgen dass der druck vor den
eu-außengrenzen weniger wird wie
erreichen wir das indem wir zum beispiel
intensiv mit bosnien herzegowina
kooperieren und es geschafft haben dass
es ein rückführungsabkommen gibt
zwischen bosnien herzegowina und
pakistan und wir dem ist beginnen die
russische regierung dabei zu
unterstützen
1200 illegal aufhältige pakistan ihm
vorstellen
die gewinner auch wieder dazu zu bringen
die rückreise anzutreten warum weil es
keine bleibe berechtigung in der
europäischen union geben wird aber
weiter eu-außengrenze eben nicht
funktioniert brauchen wir mehr
grenzüberwachung an der
österreichisch-ungarischen grenze vor
allem hier haben wir verstärkt auf
grippe festgestellt wir haben
festgestellt und auf der anderen seite
auch vermehrt schlepper festgenommen an
die 200 schon dieses jahr und das
aufgrund der hervorragenden
zusammenarbeit mit dem österreichischen
bundesheer mein aufrichtiger dank gilt
den eingesetzten soldatinnen und
soldaten polizistinnen und polizisten
vor allem der verteidigungsministerin
die hier seite an seite mit uns steht um
den grenzschutz auszubauen und für mehr
sicherheit für die republik zu sorgen
da die situation derzeit aus unserer
sicht eine sehr ernst zu nehmen dies
werden wir den assistenzeinsatz des
österreichischen bundesheeres für die
österreichische polizei im bereich der
grenzsicherung deutlich ausbauen und
erweitern
wir werden entlang der österreich
ungarischen grenze zusätzlich 400
soldaten einsetzen und sind mittlerweile
auf einem sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz niveau von tauschen
soldatinnen und soldaten an der seite
von polizistinnen und polizisten um die
grenzen österreich zu schützen
dieser assistenzeinsatz hat eine große
bedeutung für uns und für unsere
sicherheit
die eingesetzten polizistinnen und
polizisten sind vertraut mit den
eingesetzten soldatinnen und soldaten
und da den kommentierenden offizieren
und wir werden das system des
assistenzeinsatz grundlegend neu
aufstellen
wir werden ein lagezentrum im burgenland
in betrieb nehmen
das einem flexiblen grenzsicherung
einsatz ermöglicht das heißt dass sowohl
die polizei als auch die eingesetzten
soldatinnen und soldaten je nach
schwerpunkt die grenzabschnitte
überwachen das ist deshalb notwendig
geworden weil auch die schlepper vorfeld
aufklärung betreiben und dort merken wo
der kontrolldruck besonders groß ist
sofort diese routen verändern
wir werden ihnen einen strich durch die
rechnung machen durch diesen flexiblen
einsatz und das ist alles deshalb
möglich weil die zusammenarbeit mit dem
österreichischen bundesheer
vertrauensvoll ist hervorragend
funktioniert
und ich sage es hier auch gerne noch
einmal hätten wir das österreichische
bundesheer nicht hier an seite der
polizei wären wir jetzt in einer
schwierigen situation
angesichts der tatsache dass das eu
asylverfahren die asyl richtlinien der
europäischen union hier im
offensichtlich keine wirkung zeigen und
wir selbst dass österreich wieder
verstärkt unsere grenzen sichern müssen
vor verteidigungsministern ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für diesen einsatz
ich danke den soldatinnen und soldaten
und hoffe dass sie mit diesem beitrag
auch klarmachen dass wir uns einfach
nicht der situation hingeben sondern
dass österreich sich dagegen wehrt auch
dagegen wehrt dass wir von seiten der
europäischen kommission in dieser frage
im stich gelassen werden
vielen dank an minister
verteidigungsministerium bitte sehr
geehrter herr innenminister sehr geehrte
kommandanten soldatinnen soldaten sehr
geehrte polizistinnen und polizisten
sehr geehrte medienvertreter damen und
herren
der innenminister hat genannte sind die
steigenden auf griffs zahlen die es
notwendig machen dass wir gemeinsam mit
dem bundesministerium für inneres unsere
assistenzkräfte an der grenze zur
slowakei ungarn slowenien massiv
verstärken
wir werden bis zu 400 weitere
soldatinnen und soldaten zur verstärkung
an da oft und an der südgrenze stellen
um die polizei im rahmen der
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz es zu unterstützen
da dann notwendige tatsächliche genaue
bedarf der wird sich in zusammenarbeit
mit dem einsatz führenden
militärkommando burgenland um mit der
landespolizeidirektion burgenland
ergeben
daher habe ich auch bereits anordnen
lassen dass sich heute vormittag gleich
als erstes eine verstärkte kompanie des
jägerbataillons 25 von der khevenhüller
kaserne in klagenfurt aus dem weg ins
burgenland macht um in den grenzeinsatz
zu gehen
die grundlage dieses assistenzeinsatzes
sind gültige regierungsbeschlüsse und
das ziel ist es dabei
unter führung des innenministeriums
migrationsbewegungen zu kontrollieren
und unsere grenzen zu schützen
mehr unterstützen schon seit jahren
intensiv mit unseren kräften die polizei
an den grenzen und auch ich darf mich
für diese professionelle zusammenarbeit
bei ihnen herr innenminister ganz
herzlich bedanken sind aktuell 1000
soldatinnen und soldaten die hier in
ganz österreich im
sicherheitspolizeilichen einsatz
migration stehen gerade an tagen wie
diesen erlauben sie mir auch noch darauf
hinzuweisen dass daneben
assistenzeinsätze laufen und
unterstützungs einsätze laufen zu kuwait
es sind am heutigen tag circa 500 20
soldatinnen und soldaten diesbezüglich
im einsatz und dann haben wir ja auch
noch die assistenzeinsätze zur
katastrophenhilfe das sind 134 soldaten
die im einsatz sind ebenfalls im ausland
im einsatz sind 850 soldaten eingesetzt
das heißt eine gesamtsumme von 2500
soldaten die im direkten inlands und
auslandseinsätze stehen für den
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz und das auch in summe
zu nennen werden etwa 49 millionen euro
pro jahr eingesetzt
sehr geehrte damen und herren sie alle
wissen sicherheit gibt es nicht zum
nulltarif daher tragen die steuerzahler
auch zu diesem einsatz bayer bei eines
glaube ich es nach den genannten zahlen
des innenministers auch ganz klar jeder
sind ja hier investiert wird jeder sind
wir auch in das bundesheer investiert
wird der dient der sicherheit der
bevölkerung das ist ein satz an den
grenzen österreichs hat uns ausgeübt
außerdem gezeigt wie wichtig auch der
einsatz der miliz sie ist die mit
soldatinnen und soldaten
das ist auch notwendig in diesem bereich
zu investieren ich glaube ein wichtiger
schritt für die überwachung der
staatsgrenze ist nicht nur die
investition in gerät sondern auch in
eine fundierte und professionelle
ausbildung unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten
wir haben wir ein ausbildungsprogramm
geschaffen
dienst für österreich da haben wir die
basis geschaffen denn wer sich für
dieses modell entscheidet der kann beim
bundesheer nicht nur eine sechs monate
ausbildung absolvieren sondern dann auch
als gut ausgebildete und das ist wichtig
bei dieser verantwortungsvollen aufgabe
im grenzeinsatz stehen
es braucht wird diesen durchaus
anspruchsvollen einsatz an der grenze
eine intensive eine gute ausbildung die
wir ohne zweifel mit diesem modell
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten bieten
können und damit einen wesentlichen
beitrag auch leisten können für den
schutz unserer bevölkerung sehr geehrte
damen und herren erlauben sie mir eine
abschließende bemerkung die vergangenen
monate haben eines eindrucksvoll gezeigt
egal ob bei der bekämpfung der pandemie
mit den gesundheitsbehörden bei den
aufräumarbeiten nach dem hochwasser vom
letzten wochenende gemeinsam mit der
feuerwehr oder eben beim grenzschutz uhr
innenminister mit der polizei unser heer
unsere soldaten sind immer da wenn sie
gebraucht werden schulter an schulter in
diesem fall mit dem polizisten kämpfen
wir zum schutz der bevölkerung die
sicherheit unseres landes zu wahren das
ist unsere gemeinsame aufgabe und die
kooperation zwischen dem bundesheer und
der polizei funktioniert und zeigt eines
dass wir sicherheit nur gemeinsam am
besten sicherstellen können dankeschön
vielen dank frau verteidigungsministerin
ich darf sie nun um ihre fragen bitten
die erste frage bitte orf verbiegen
moment es kommt es kommt ein mikrofon
vielleicht im kurzen moment warten bitte
keine minister sie begründen das ganze
auch damit dass sie sagen
die zahl der aufgriffe ist gestiegen
können sie das beziffern inwieweit die
gestiegen sind wie viele festnahmen gibt
es das dann wird sich das entwickelt in
den letzten monaten und auch im
vergleich zu den letzten jahren
wir haben
jetzt schon das heißt vom ersten bis zum
juli 2021 15 1768 aufgriffe wir hatten
2020 gesamt 21.700 aufgriffe also sie
sehen wir haben eine steigende zahl und
es ist aus meiner sicht völlig
inakzeptabel dass wir steigende aufgriff
zahlen haben vonseiten ungarn nach
österreich
dass wir aufgrund der erkenntnisse der
europäischen höchstgerichte nach ungarn
dublin fälle nicht zurückstellen können
ungarn hat eine außengrenze mit serbien
das heißt mit einem drittstaat das heißt
österreich ist von irregulärer migration
unmittelbar betroffen und ich habe
seither und ich bin seitdem ich
innenminister bin daran die kommission
von dieser ernsten situation zu
informieren mehrfach darauf hinzuweisen
vor allem die kommissarin johannsen die
hier haupt zuständig ist und wir haben
seither keine unterstützung von seiten
der kommission erhalten ganz im
gegenteil die kommission hält sich eher
damit aufnahme über verteilungsfragen zu
diskutieren die im europäischen kontext
völlig sinnlos sind weil es dafür keine
mehrheit geben wird die kommission hält
sich damit auch wenn sie daran denken
und deswegen schicken wir auch jetzt
eine sondereinheit der cobra an die
liebt weißrussische grenze die
kommission hält sich lieber damit auf
die liter in der frage der aufnahme
zentren zu unterstützen
aber lässt die litauische
innenministerin und das hat sie mir
selbst berichtet vollkommen im stich
wenn es darum geht die litauer dabei zu
unterstützen eine grenzschutz anlage zu
errichten sprich einen saum dafür gibt
es keine unterstützung aber für
aufnahmezentren das sind die falschen
signale die wir von seiten der
europäischen union in die welt schicken
es ist auch das falsche signal dass der
europäische union richtung weißrussland
schickt wir lassen uns das europäische
union nicht von ländern adressen die
versuchen mit ihr regulärer migration
druck auf unsere politik auszuüben
deshalb erste unterstützung vonseiten
österreichs für litern wir lassen
niemanden alleine in diesem grenzfragen
wir sind solidarisch so wie damals mit
griechenland und gleichzeitig geben
unsere bemühung
und nochmals danke an die verteidigung
ministerin daher auch unsere eigenen
grenzen noch stärker zu überwachen
nächste frage bitte angelides von atv
noch mal nachgefragt sie haben sitzt
zwar schon von der kommission
angesprochen aber eben auch mal was
läuft ganz konkret eben schief an den
außengrenzen was wer ist der konkret
verantwortlich und weiters noch welt die
entwicklungen in welchem land macht
ihnen dabei aktuellen lage am meisten
sorge ich nehme an da wird jetzt auch
afghanistan seien dennoch sind sie herr
minister verstärkt für abschiebungen
dorthin
wie passt das zusammen zum einen sind
wir jetzt gerade die verhandlungen zum
thema asyl und migration spark innerhalb
der europäischen union
österreich ist dabei eine koalition der
willigen zu bilden und hier verbündete
zu suchen damit die kommission beginnt
ihre blockadehaltung zu verändern denn
die kommission setzt derzeit nur auf dem
man also dort wo keine zustimmung
erzielt wird schon angesprochen von mir
die verteilungsfrage wichtig ist das
umzusetzen wo einigkeit besteht
einigkeit besteht unter den eu 27
mitgliedsländern dass der grenzschutz
verstärkt werden muss das schnellere
asylverfahren braucht und dass es rasche
und effiziente rückführungen gibt da
sind zb auch die deutschen unsere
verbündete horst seehofer unterstützt
jede initiative österreich dass wir so
viel als möglich jetzt noch nach
afghanistan tatsächlich auch zurück
schieben können so lange es geht auch um
das signal zu senden dass es keinen sinn
macht sich auf den weg zu machen
es kann nicht sein dass deutschland und
österreich das afghanistan problem löst
und andere sich gemütlich zurücklehnen
und sagen naja schauen wir mal wird die
zurechtkommen
wir haben große
sicherheitsherausforderungen der
dänische migrationsminister ehemalige
kommunist mittlerweile sozial ist das
ganz klar auf den punkt gebracht und das
ist damit auch ein verbündeter für uns
wir alle leben in einem der schönsten
wohlfahrt staaten auf der welt das ist
so will dänemark als auch österreich und
sowie die dänen müssen auch wir
österreicherinnen und österreicher und
menschen die in österreich leben darauf
achten dass dieser wohlfahrtsstaat nicht
gibt dass unsere systeme nicht
überlastet werden
und daher ist das jetzt aus meiner sicht
richtig und wichtig die installiert
initiativen zu setzen und ja natürlich
macht mir die lage in afghanistan sorgen
aber gerade deshalb ist es notwendig so
lange es geht möglichst viele die nicht
hier bleiben dürfen nach afghanistan
zurück zu schieben und wenn dann die
lage in afghanistan gibt die frage zu
stellen warum ist es notwendig dass ein
afghane in österreich einen asylantrag
stellt diese flucht route führt durch
bis zu zehn sicheren ländern und damit
reden wir nicht mehr von asyl als
fluchtgrund sondern wir reden von
migration und diese diskussion muss ich
auch die europäische union stehe
österreich verfügt gemessen an der
bevölkerung über einer der größten
afghanischen community es innerhalb der
europäischen union mit vielen
herausforderungen wie sie alle wissen
das heißt es ist hier ganz klar auch
unser ansinnen dass die kommission nicht
länger sagt was österreich alles tun
soll sondern dass die kommission den weg
ändert und sagt wie können wir
österreich helfen denn wir gehören zu
den meist belastenden ländern innerhalb
der europäischen union 130000 menschen
bekommen schutz gewährt von uns da sind
wir an der dritten stelle das heißt 24
eu mitgliedsländer leisten weniger
schutz
ein guter grund hier alle acht
aufzufordern nicht wegzuschauen sondern
hinzuschauen und mit deutschland als
verbündeten mit denen mag mit den
niederlanden mit belgien haben wir eine
gruppe die auch eine stimme hat
innerhalb der europäischen union plus
ungarn + tschechiens polens den anderen
staaten
es ist keine frage mehr der visegrad
staaten an sich es ist eine frage von
europäischen interesse wie wir mit dem
thema asyl und migration für die zukunft
umgehen gibt es weitere fragen sehe
keine weiteren fragen zu sagen einmal
noch orf ja eine kurze frage noch zu den
zahlen
das heißt 400 kommen zusätzlich und
insgesamt sind dann 1000
soldaten sind ineinander grenze sie an
das hauptsächlich grundwehrdiener sein
oder andere wohltaten verteilt sich das
auf nachfrage er selbst die
verteidigungsministerien stellung nehmen
das was für uns beide ein wichtiger
rahmen ist dass es ein abkommen gibt
dass wir in einer ausnahmesituation je
nach bedrohungslage bis zu 2000
soldatinnen und soldaten für den
assistenzeinsatz abrufen können ich weiß
dass das eine große bürde und
herausforderung ist auch für die
verteidigungsministerin für die
soldatinnen und soldaten die da
eingesetzt werden
aber wir sind dankbar dass wir jetzt die
aufstockung durchführen konnten die
verteidigungsministerium
verteidigungsministerium hat schon
ausgeführt dass die lage laufend
evaluiert wird und wir werden alles dazu
tun dass die grenzen geschützt sind aber
zu den details die
verteidigungsministerin es werden bis zu
400 soldatinnen und soldaten gestellt
werden
gesamt im einsatz nicht nur an der
grenze zum osten sind es 1000 und unser
ziel dass er mit dem programm ein dienst
für österreich gemacht worden ist ist
dass es in der minderzahl
grundwehrdiener sind daher auch wie
gesagt in diesen in der nächsten halben
stunde eine kompanie des jägerbataillons
25 wo maximal eine handvoll
grundwehrdiener mit dabei ist weil wir
eben dafür sorgen wollen dass
tatsächlich nur gut ausgebildete
soldaten an der grenze eben im einsatz
sind wir haben mit diesem modell mein
dienst für österreich das heißt der
freiwilligen verpflichtung für drei
weitere monate bereits über 600 junge
männer erreichen können und die sind
nach dem grundwehrdienst so ausgebildet
dass wir sie gut hier
für diese so wichtige
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz tätigkeit verwenden
können
derzeit sind 600 an der grenze wo wir
verstärken das heißt bis zu 400 kommen
dann noch dazu je nach bedarf solange
der assistenzeinsatz notwendig ist so
wie bei jedem anderen
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz kommt die vorgabe eben
über die anfahrende behörde
und jetzt einmal ist glaube ich die
grenze bis zu den nächsten paar monaten
glaube ich festgelegt und das wird ja
laufend evaluiert je nach dem bedarf
sowohl was die dauer des
assistenzeinsatzes anbelangt als auch
was die anzahl der notwendigen
soldatinnen und soldaten am belag weil
einst führend ist eben dann die polizei
die landespolizeidirektion im binnenland
und unser militär kommando im burgenland
das laufend nach aktueller lage
evaluiert sowohl die notwendige anzahl
als auch die dauer
vielen dank kann man diese steigerung an
aufgriff zehn prozent zahlen müssen
[Musik]
naja sie sehen sie an den zahlen ansicht
dass es eine große steigerung gibt wenn
sie daran denken dass wir letztes jahr
in summe 21.700 aufgriffe hatten und
jetzt schon mitte des jahres 15.700 also
allein die reine zahlen logik sagt uns
dass wir es hier mit einem verstärkten
druck zu tun haben wir müssen uns selbst
helfen
wir müssen selbst darauf schauen dass
unsere grenzen sicher sind dass wir
wissen mehr in unser land kommen will
und wir müssen gleichzeitig dafür werben
dass die europäische union hier in die
gänge kommt und endlich auch nägel mit
köpfen macht gut nachdem ich sehe keine
weiteren fragen gibt schließlich die
pressekonferenz bedanken fürs kommen
wieder hin